everyone to my talk I'm going to talk
about Flair which is a system that we
developed with my advisor at Purdue
University so I'm gregarious hotel and
my advisor is chakram
also a lot of people in my group
involved in that project so I I don't
remember we don't have to forget them um
so pure University is it's a big
University in Indiana so it's pretty
during the summer a little bit less
during the winter so don't be careful
and if you fly across the United States
between Indianapolis and Chicago so it's
in the Midwest not too far from here
so we are going to talk about Apache
spark so how many of you know about
spark are you using it for your work and
so the idea is like how many of you use
park we've data more than 10 gigabytes
more than 100 gigabytes more than 1
terabyte ok so our idea is that the more
we ask I mean the AIA I asked the less
people were actually using spark with
big data and the the goal of that talk
is to show that the current state of
spark is very focused on big data very
large data right a terabyte for example
but when it comes to smaller data sites
like 100 gigabytes there is a lot of
machine nowadays that can actually have
that much memory like we have a machine
at in our group that has twitter a bytes
of memory right so when we have 100
terabytes of memory I was 100 gigabytes
of data that we want to under want to
have all the runtime of spark that
actually is developed for distributed
system so in 2011 spark was developed by
meteo and it was at beginning just a
library like like a kind of my produce I
love a library that user could actually
under big write big data and do data
processing much more easily but
it has been extended to be much more
than just a library it become a full
framework with data frame that has been
introduced so that our frame were kind
of different API that allows the user to
build using the top language or Python
or Java or Scala and then there is much
more front-end now but when we use spark
instead of actually computing thing we
build a model then that model is
optimized by catalyst and then some code
generation happen and finally the code
is run on on your system through the LED
the FDD framework so LED stand for
resilient distributed data set and that
is really used for when you have a
distributed system there is a well
problem with the network so sometimes
some nodes could break and you have to
rerun your code so all of that
resilience is built in the idea and so
like we we want to use Park to first
have very fast and efficient data
processing like faster than a dupe but
it was in the day we are going to figure
out our fastest park so for example if
we have a data set of the Engram which
is a data set containing like statistic
about world that how they appear during
the inner in the book since the since
they have been booked right so I don't
know that data set and we are going to
do some experiment on it right so we are
going to do a small demo I hope
everybody can see so i wrote a small
demo with some pre process stuff so not
nothing very fancy but i'm going to show
you so we have a we say okay where is a
file in our program we on my computer
what is a field so there is words your
occurrence and the number of book for
each one and then we are going to just
load it and create a temporary table for
the g book right and here I have some
some code to India
swiftly so like Flair and skull and
Spock are both implemented in Scala they
both run on the GBM and 2005 both of
them we just have to run the GBM with
the corresponding with the job that we
want to have so here I just have a small
micro that run java with both spark and
flare as a jar file okay okay so we read
it so we have we are using a sparker 2.0
I'm going to load our demo file okay
and and we can create a data frame so
the data frame like we have our G book
already our G book data frame and we
want to do some operation on top of it
so for example we want to filter on the
column world all right we have a column
wall and we want to see how many of the
world argument for example right so the
the G book file that we are loading is
about two gigabytes of memory right so
for you that are using spark it's
supposed to be fast so how much time it
should spend to actually execute that
query an idea okay so sometimes people
say false again ten-second this cancer
why we have to get to go through the
file and just filter okay so here first
we create a data frame nothing happened
because we didn't actually request an
i/o but I'm going to time soon to ask
for Flair prospect to actually show us
the result so there is some launching of
the data frame at one point we are going
to see a progress bar that is going to
tell us what is the current state of the
of the primate so stage one is being
computed most likely there is a scan and
then a filter right so the spark first
have to load the data in memory and then
do undo the processing so it's taking
quite a while only for two gigabytes of
memory right so we would like we are
going to see later what is the reason
right why Park is that slow when we say
it's actually fast when we talk about
Big Data
so to two gigabyte is not big data right
so that's why maybe all the mechanism
added to spark 200 big data do not add
much in that case and so a lot of my
time in that talk is actually waiting
for back to actually compute
unit should be if you should take about
one minute and 20 second I think I mean
when I when I run the demo earlier I had
to restart my computer's of no caching
and nothing but okay I'm out there I
think there is no more than to state so
that should be okay so we have 20 row
that are showing so they don't show all
the row and it take 90 second right so I
told you that flare is an accelerator so
I have I have at the end of my demo of
some code that could interface with
flare which is running in the GBM like
spa so right now I'm going to call play
on my data frame and what Fleur does
return an object which is a flare data
frame and but you have the exact same
operation that you could do in Sparks so
flare is completely transparent for the
spark user it just transforming into
another data frame with the same
operation so here I call flare and we
are going to have two timings so here on
the timing is the time it took to
actually compile the code and then here
we have the time that actually runs
records right we went from one work from
90-second too fast again by using for
them so now the question is like I'm
going to go back to Maya I know I can
I'm going to launch a smaller smaller
dim so we can also do some SQL so spark
as a front time for SQL and for example
if we do a little bigger crazy so cpc-h
is a benchmark that I'm going to use
later but it's it's a in the industrial
benchmark that tried to see how well SQL
Craig walk so here I have an SQL query
which is little bit more involved which
to filter with many condition and do an
aggregation on the result okay and so
I'm going to start by by crying the data
frame so we have the second way of
creating so that our family to do is
using directly the SQL fronting so up
something so we have a data frame and we
are going to run it with we flare first
and then we were run
so flair is yes it's a little bit more
inverse for the computation the
computation time for our system was a
little bit higher of 1.2 second but then
it ran also pretty fast and if I if I
run with out transforming the data frame
into a flare data frame first so it's
going to run with with spark and it's
going to take more than false again but
we can come later to see how long it
took we don't I don't really want to
wait for that ok so we did the de bomb
but now the question is is why why are
we I mean we know that spark has been
Indian nearby a lot of people in the
community it has been a well optimized
so there is no reason that they could
not be as fast as we are right so so the
reason is just a design decision
like I said spark is made for big data
and what we are doing here is only for 2
gigabytes or 1 gigabyte so in the in
that range so there's two aspects so the
first one is like the LED system we are
we on one machine right it's on my
laptop there is like 10 gigabytes of
memory and I don't need to learn all the
RDD in the background to in case that
the computation do not walk to relaunch
it right it's very unlikely to have
memory errors there is a lot of hardware
correction mechanism that can open in my
computer and the chance of actually
having an error here is very low so all
of that overhead is not really useful
right so there's another aspect it's a
code generation so our the code
generation walk is that spark is
generating java code at runtime right so
here for example it's it's a code for
the broadcast joyed so we don't have to
go they in deep in detail but that
function is actually really generated
the java code right and which is a piece
of string which is then compiled and
then run into the LED system and a lot
of the way that it happens there's many
pipeline right like like it's parallel
we want to have many pipeline like that
one can be run on the machine another
one can be run another machine but you
know ok is same thing we don't have
multiple mesh
we are in the same shared memory so if
we start to have different pipeline and
we have to stand data between the two
pipeline like if it was on two different
machine we're actually adding a lot of
overhead right so here for example is
generating the the matches here
it's calling as next it's like an
iterative process so every time in the
loop we will have a callback mechanism
to go and ask do you are you going to
send me more data and so on so although
that is adding a lot of overhead and at
the end when we were running the last
query that I ran on spark all of that is
actually extracting data from the the
iterator that I show you so most of the
time is spent decoding the in-memory
representation for for the data rather
than doing the computation and I think
if we go back to the computation it
should be done right so it took 40 one
second okay so on and most of this time
has been spending to decoding the
in-memory data processing so what do we
do we flare like how do we achieve
actually that performance back by
bypassing the to the two system that we
are thinking are at fault right and like
catalyst is a square query optimizer oh
it's everything is done as the eye level
right we have an SQL plan and we can
apply a level optimization and catalyst
is doing it very well
so we extract that data plan and we do
our own code generation and now code
generation instead of targeting gvm and
RDD system we generate low-level C code
which is a one standalone file that
actually is going to wake to compute
exactly what the query was about right
so we generate one piece of binary that
can do only one thing complete only one
value the one that was requested by the
user and one of the advantage with that
is that we can interface with other
system such as tensorflow that do the
same thing that you can compile your
code to native code and then interface
them very efficiently and if we know the
the way of tons of our tensor flow is
actually
representing is data we can also use the
same representation and when we actually
want tens of you to execute data on the
data we are actually loading we don't
have to do any transformation we don't
have to do any copy so all of that
boundary between the two system are
completely removed and at the end I will
do a demo which turns off flow to show
how it actually also increase the
performance very much so um I did a demo
on some example but right now I'm going
to focus on like what are the result for
our system okay so first we are going to
look on a single Corrin machine right so
we want to know what's the best we can
do on one one single cause one single
foot and the cheapest edge benchmark
that I mentioned before has 22 queries
that are multiple aggregate drawing
operation a filter and all of the SQL
thing and here the the tests are made on
data set of size 10 12 gigabytes right
and in a memory in a machine that has
much more than that so we can see that
we we compare four different system we
compare Postgres which is a very
old-fashioned database system which is a
which is not really in memory processing
right we compare spark which has been
okay now we don't really want to use the
disk let's put everything in memory and
we compare with i / which is the
state-of-the-art system which is closed
it's not open source right the the
published on paper on how they design
the IP in a way but it's not open source
and it's generating LLVM code and we
compare with flare which we generate
low-level seeker and we can see that
there is two group of system there is
the one that are slow and the one that
down a little bit faster so progress and
spark are actually very similar even if
it's a log I'd scales so sometime spark
is still much faster than power squares
but it's not that much right so the fact
that we remove all the
the disk access and putting into memory
didn't really help much in that case for
spark because we are on the one fret
right I'm not trying to say that spark
will will not work on distributed system
but on one thread is like surely not the
best and then I burn flour almost
similar on almost every cry and for for
the it's more difference is mainly we
think small engineering details ok and
and there's also one other aspect that
we can do when we when we generate code
is to improve the loading time because
most of the time we could focus on
computation right but there is also the
loading time that when you are on a
single machine it can be very important
because you you cannot keep all your
data in in memory when you run multiple
job but so when we go from CSV to
actually in memory representation we
need to decode the the file and most of
the time that decode is done by a
general-purpose library right you have
you have a library that can decode any
CSV file but we realized that well if
you know that your schema is going to be
one integer than one double then
wunderbar you just have to write code
that first pass an integer and then pass
to the ball you don't have to actually
have a dispatch function that every time
or what is the next thing right so what
we do when we generate code we remove
all the indirection by using all the
information we have statically which is
in our case the relation schema okay and
so also we we have a packet decoder
which is a binary and columnar
representation already it has been
encoded for easy access and we can see
that in both case being able to
specialize your code for the given file
you have rather than using
general-purpose CSV Reader give you a
very very big advantage even with when
we pass CSV file we are faster than when
spark
pass a binary file okay so now we have
seen on one flat but we know that we
have many cars on a machine so let's try
to use our machine to the full potential
so to first talk about what is there
where we are using so we did our
experiment on a new machine which has
four circuits each circuits have 256
gigabytes of memory and each circuit has
1818 Co okay so total we have 100
terabyte of memory and we can have a 96
cause 1996 file ok so here we we do a
comparison between flare and spark on 1
2 4 8 16 and 32 thread and and we plot
it so we can see that spark on the top
right as a very good scaling right it's
every time we add more thread spark is
faster
there is Molly curve that we are going
to talk about and and flare is not too
bad but a little bit not as good as back
in terms of pure scaling so the question
is why why that so there is a blog
article by Mac Sheree that's called
scalability but at what cost and cost is
is mean I added in my note on our but
it's the idea is how many thread do you
need in spark to beat the best one
threaded application right so if we look
at for example Q 14 well we know that
even when we multiply the number of
thread at one point we will never been
as fast as Flair into with one thread so
the cost of spark or getting to flair is
infinity even if we have an infinity
number of thread in spark we will never
be as good as Flair with one for it and
the reason is because of the also
inherent bottleneck and overhead that I
talked about in in spark right so
we can try to look a little bit more
translate to the to the result but here
we have a sharp decrease when we go to
16 to 32 threads so there any idea why
while it happens so the thing I remove
it we have 18 copper circuits so when we
want 32 we need to use two circuits
right and when we start to use two
circuits now we have a program because
we are in a machine which is it doesn't
have uniform memory access
so the code we generate cannot just be
the same than before because or at least
when we load data we have to be very
careful on which circuit we want to load
the data to avoid cross first circuit
communication so here they call the the
the result is we found new my
optimization so we are going to so so
just to remember to have an idea is if I
load my memory into the first core
memory band and I want to like to
execute my code on the fourth circuit
well we have to have an burst access
rather than a direct access to the
memory and so we opted Numa optimization
and then we did some tests so there is a
lot of thing happening in that graphic
so we are going to take some time so the
light-blue means that we run all our
thread into one circuit so we did two
experiment one with one thread and one
with 18:4 okay and so we see that while
we have a good so the number here is is
speed-up right so with 18 thread on one
circuit we get 12 speed up for for q1
and 18:14 speed up for q6 so it's pretty
good it I mean it's not the full the
full 18 because we still have overhead
and we added of course but then what is
interesting is when we go to two
circuits when we use 18 thread on two
circuits we have nine hundred one and
nine on the other with new my
optimization we see that well it doesn't
change much for q1 but for q6 we have a
22 speed-up right so while it's there
must be some
noise ins in the computation because
it's very fast so having the speed up to
be 22 it's a little bit too much but
still why do why is it more than 14 well
the reason is that Cusick is is actually
memory bound right so if Q 1 is CPU bond
and Q 6 is memory bound so which means
that when we use two circuits we are
virtually x 2 the memory bandwidth which
make that now q 6 can can be much more
efficient because it can load data twice
faster right and when we go to 4 so cat
we can see that we have the same thing
like even on small circuit so memory
bandwidth can be can be seen okay and so
we pin the thread on each circuit to
make sure that when I load the data on
that circuit it with the thread that is
going to access that data is always
going to be on the given circuit okay
and and now I'm going to talk about
attentional workload so I'm not sure
about the time because everything has
been a little bit shuffle but we should
be over now I think I have more ten
minutes so I'll try to go fast for you
to go get coffee so we are going to see
what happened when we try to to
interface with tons of leg with tons of
floss so we Colossus time tens of layers
so the overall architecture of Larry is
like that so assuming we want to
interface with a system that create the
binary as we do well we can actually
merge everything into one big binary
that is specialized data loading that is
under by flair and then the data
processing which is under linked by two
things the SQL engine and the the
tensorflow binary so tons of flow can be
compiled using excel at - it's it's a
tons of flow compiler to give us a
low-level binary okay so we go back to
the demo so here instead of using a
scaler I'm going to use Python because
tensorflow
is using Python so we are going to do a
query
that is using a classifier here so
classifier will be a will be a tons of
flow model which is a simple matrix
multiplication on data that time I
manually I mean randomly generated and
the classifier is already has already
been already been trained and is going
to do clustering and then we do here
it's to do a matrix confusion matrix so
we are going to display a confusion
matrix okay same thing I'm going to show
you how it works so here is my model
work that has already been trained by by
me and then I out cut it here just for
simplicity here is a classifier that is
going to be using the Python so we we
are going to use our model and and
compute and get the the TF Micmac so we
extract what is what is more likely
class for for input and one is one thing
is important is how we actually generate
the the binary with tons of flow is by
using the code called TF GF compile
right so TF compile takes the
representation in the Python that python
is be linked aching the graph and
generate a binary with some c++ header
that flare can actually pass and then in
a user to to generate code okay and then
same thing we have some kind of
interface we've run with excuse me the
gvm that is a running flare in the
background so I'm going to launch by
spark ok I'm going to execute the file
for the demo so my the first demo I'm
going to do is using two hundred data
point so it's just because I want it to
be fast so in the file we have two
hundred data point okay so first we have
to to compile the the model
up so I'm going to compile the motor up
of course there we go so here we have a
small arrow it's just a warning so it
has been already be done so right now I
say ok I told to flare here we go we
have the model which is the Python code
that is going to be executed because
when we come back we always every time
there is a UDF function even for spark
we need to register it right we need to
tell which function we are we are using
and and it is used through a UDF
register in inflow as well so I did that
so now if I create a data frame up with
spark SQL on the query ok here we go up
we can run it using spark so same thing
here like like we are there's a smaller
small warning same thing so here we are
going to do ok so it took 9 second let's
see how it took with flare ok a 1.2 so
1.2 second for compute for compilation
but then the code run in 100 100
microsecond right so I can show you the
code that has been generated actually
it's very ugly but it's very fast and so
the thing is
well it's only 200 point right so we see
that the 100 1.2 second to compile just
to 200 point is not that great because
park take only while it take 10 seconds
so it's still better but I mean we want
to see what happened when we use a
bigger big animal so what I'm going to
do is executor run a file that choose
more 2000
okay sorry
okay so we have that we are going to
create that iframe so I don't have to
actually recompile the regenerate the
model like I did before because it's
already cashed in flair but I could it
it's going to work the same thing but
okay and so let's now run just flair to
start with okay so up same thing
compiled in 1.2 and it took a little bit
more time but now we can see that it's
the same almost the same computation
time just because most of the time is
pending in the computation process and
now if I run I'm going to run with spark
but I think even before the end of the
of the talk is not going to actually be
able to terminate so we can come back
later again okay and so how do we
achieve that right so we have we we
publish to paper on the subject so the
one in Sigma it is more about our two
architecture cray compiler so it
explains the design of the system and
then a one which is to be appeared in
OSD I that is actually doing I mean the
presentation I made about today's is a
little bit more detail in into the paper
so if you want to check out they're all
free access on the internet and and so
like we we are just using our system on
on the tepees edge benchmark and on some
data that we can find ourselves we would
like to see if some of you are
interested to use the system on some of
your data and see we can actually help
you to to accelerate you your code and
help us to make our system better we
have we have a beta program that you you
may want to send us an email and them
and we can maybe find something so
that's the end of my talk I have no idea
how I did in time but thank you
so further question I forgot to say that
I can use the app I can use anything in
the of do you know what's the code for
the room or anything otherwise I'm okay
to take question like yeah yes
okay so the for the question is about
the licensing so if you contact us for
the beta program I mean my advisor will
be more in charge of that but the I
think the idea will be to have like a
command-i code to actually be able to
just improve our system and and see how
it goes
after I don't it's not open source yet
so I don't know if my adviser want to do
it at one point or not I think it's
going to happen but right now I don't
really have a lot of information about
that yes so those are cashing right now
what we generate is a standalone program
so every time we run it it we have to
rerun it so the next generation we are
going to look into distributed system
because it's somehow more important and
we also want to have a client-server
system right we have we would like to
have one server that cache all the data
that has already been loading right and
then every time you have a query instead
of running launching a new process we
can say to that process that is already
running can you run that binary using
the data that you already have
potentially so we are going to add some
kind of just-in-time compilation as well
based on what is available in the server
like all that computation has already be
done I'm not going to do it this time
and so on so yes we are going to to look
into into that yes
on earth so you mean on on the beach
crazy Oh like we we are only on one
machine we spark never to cover right so
now if we start to distribute it I'm
sure that we will have to add a lot of
overhead as well so but but the thing
also which is interesting that even if
we keep the RTD we could generate code
to be run into the IDE and keep all the
distributed for flair for a spark as
well right
so instead of using their Java
implementation we could use our
implementation that still fuse some of
the code so yeah I have no idea how much
but I mean right now we have a one
terabyte machine and we never used much
more than that so yeah well thank you
so the thing is it depend how much is
your so like we we support everything
which is a data frame right so if you
the code that you are using is doing a
lot of user-defined function for example
that are defined in Python or in Scala
that cannot actually it's a black box
even for our system right one of the
problem with UDF is mostly a black box
for the optimizer but it's the same form
for us so if every time we want to call
a UDF we have to do a context switch and
do a call to that function that can be a
big limitation yes unless the code is
written in a way that can interface more
easily with our system there is a way
but that will require require much more
refactoring right not as transparent
that as we would like to be right now
you know right now it's we want to have
the same user-friendly interface that
Spock as and and to have just a big
benefit when you want to run on a single
machine thank you very much
[Applause]